First off notation wise, they correspond to the concrete operations.
We're going to have variables Q sub 1,
Q sub 2, so on, to correspond to the abstract ones which were the Ps.
And similarly to correspond to the abstract state which was indicated by s.
We're going to have the concrete state indicated by t as
a typical concrete state element. And capital T as the set of concrete states.
And then, the interesting one is that we're going to introduce a function,
a retrieve function. Here, I'm using retr as an abbreviation for it. And it's
going to map from concrete states to abstract ones. That is, retrieve on some t,
concrete state t, is going to be corresponding to some abstract state s.
And it's always going to be the case that, t goes to a single s.
However, it might be the case that different ts go to the same s.
You kind of expect that because at the lower level we have more details. And so,
we can get into more states. But
those states are going to map into a fewer number of abstract states.